nous allons maintenant rejoindre en
direct au ministère de la culture à
paris michèle vial avec je crois à ses
côtés jack lang pour un premier bilan de
cette fête de la musique 91
michel est ce que vous n'avez pas tout
de même le sentiment que cette fête qui
a donc maintenant dix ans c'est un petit
peu institutionnalisée embourgeoisé
qu'elle a perdu un peu de sa spontanéité
écoutez très franchement je vous avoue
que je n'ai pas entendu votre question
vous le pensez on ya énormément breillat
rien ou yanis handler qui sont un de
jouer tout à l'heure il y aura mory
kanté mai prochain quand je me demande
si ça c'est la vitrine c'est les stars
de la musique internationale mais le
plus important c'est pas le petit
village la manifestation plus petits
villages de france
c'est vrai vous avez raison et vos
images n'ont rien paraître à distance et
lâche contre
partout à travers
villes et villages des banlieues cet
après midi par exemple
de quoi inquiéter
des orchestres des musiciens isolé ce
décès de partout
la fête tels que jamais trompé exposé
amis
original immédiat
le goût de la musique c'est un don c'est
un temps qui peut s'enseigner qui peut
s'améliorer si un couac aujourd'hui par
m parce que les enseignants de la
musique qui sont un peu en colère un peu
en grève nous pouvons donc pas vous
enseignant de la belgique
il oriente
personne
dernière question vous êtes pour la
chaîne musicale ya pas de chaises
musicales depuis la disparition de tv6
en 1987 alors que tu vois qu'on n'avait
pas beaucoup d influence parce que vous
avez beau dire vous êtes où elle
n'arrive pas là pour constater
on sait que l'audiovisuel totalement
indépendant je connaissais
je
place depuis trois ans la recréation de
recherche musicale et j'y vois des
squares et sera entendu un jour merci
accord ouvre la possibilité à vos
marques
merci messieurs